were talking a little bit about the us
open right about the big golf uh
extravaganza this week just down the
road here
in torrey pines so uh we'd like to bring
in
a rich lerner from the golf channel
to talk about it rich how you doing
buddy
ryan how are you buddy i'm doing really
well thanks for uh taking some time to
talk a little golf with us today
i always like talking golf i talk
breaking bad
i talk basketball if you want i talk
bagels but uh i seem to specialize in
talking golf
my wife would say you specialize in
talking period
i'm one i'm one of those dudes who um i
come home
and i can't quite drop the announcer's
stick
hi honey i'm home hey what's for dinner
oh my that chicken looks outstanding
three of the last four nights five of
the last nine
i'll be back for dessert after this time
out
and a word from albany
[Laughter]
i tend to do it with my kid a lot too
about you know just uh
enunciating and uh and there's been many
a time over the last year because i've
been doing a lot of radio at home he
says
dad dad you're too loud you're too loud
and so i i fully i fully get
uh that point of thing speaking about
loud what phil mickelson did
a few weeks ago at the pga championship
as a 50 year old man in dominating
fashion on the longest
set up in pga uh grand slam golf history
he heads into this event at home and of
course he's won out
before before the redo of course um
and is a 71 a 70-1 uh
underdog what do you think phil's
chances are
this weekend uh starting up on thursday
i mean look
uh it's good question um
you know the odds for anybody
to win back-to-back majors are long and
it's just too hard it's too deep now
um so let's jump forward here let's
dream a little bit
let's play the if he does pull this off
game
what are we what are we looking at then
uh with due respect
to let's go all the way back to francis
we met in 1913 who upset
the the two greats from from britain
to bobby jones in 1930 to hogan in 53
nicholas in 86 tiger woods i don't know
four times
97 2000 at pebble 08 here at tory in
2019 at augusta with due respect to
to everyone from we met to woods if
mickelson wins back-to-back majors
at age 50 and tomorrow he turns 51 to
complete the career grand slam meaning
having won all four majors to become the
sixth to have ever done it
and he does in his own backyard that's
the greatest achievement in the history
of the sport
that that's what's on the line this week
um if if he yeah if he hadn't won
kiwa and he's playing you know the way
he's playing i'd say
you know long shot but not out of the
question
uh the key will be you know keeping the
ball on
on the face of the earth uh drive it the
way he drove it at tiwa
if he does that we know his short game
is you know is all time
you know he's one of the best small ball
players in the history of the sport
if if he drives it reasonably well
doesn't swing for the fences although
his swing
does look pretty good right now then i
give him an outside shot um
and man if he's there on sunday
this place is going to be bananas uh i i
say that wherever phil could play on
mars
and it would feel like a home game uh
let alone here in san diego he grew up
in rancho santa fe
i mean you know it's such an it's such a
a great story he won the junior worlds
here
41 years ago you know they played his
first professional event here in the
late 80s
the fact that he is still relevant at
this age
i think speaks to a few things
his passion for the sport for what he
does is still as robust as ever
he's not jaded in any way uh he's
chasing it
uh as if he were a rookie he's still
curious he's willing to experiment and
risk
uh he's into it the lack of a better
phrase he's as
into it as he's ever been
and then i think the other key and you
can see this plainly on your television
screen is he is as fit today
uh at almost 51 as he was at 30. in fact
in fact he's in better shape go by the
pictures
he was uh he was heavy and and they're
heavier than i think he would have liked
to to be you know 20 25 years ago
uh he's flexible he has a long swing
which is
is great for longevity um and he's still
he's still driven and i think you know
the last factor here is
you know he spent an entire career in
tiger woods shadow
and and the two are are still lording
over the sport
which is mind-boggling you know we're
we're here at torrey pines and we're
doing a lot of reflecting
this week on what happened in 2008
because you can't help
but do it it was one of the three four
greatest majors
you know it's a debate for another day
of all time uh and tiger's not here
and now mickelson arrives uh and he
all eyes are on phil in fact i can't
recall uh
a major outside of anything tiger ever
played in right because
you know tiger's different where where
the focus was so squarely on one
person as it is this week on film
so this is 30 years on he won his first
tour event 1991 as an amateur
and he is still along with tiger in in a
way
still lording over the sport these are
two this is stating the obvious but i
state this
to to to make a point that
the caliber of star these are two
enormous television stars
tiger and phil and there's
it takes time but there's no one no one
in this newer generation has identified
themselves
uh as as a star of this magnitude
uh charismatic uh good players
likely great players i mean we have some
guys who are headed for five
six i don't know seven majors when all
is said and done
um but you know we're still
we're still fixated on phil yeah it's uh
he was an exceptional um
person when i was in san diego with the
chargers going through
my tough times he was a guy that you
know simply was supportive in every
realm and i remember him so fondly
meeting his family
tina and and uh and and uh
his his brother who's on his bag now and
and amy as well so
i i if he does win i'm gonna be seventy
thousand dollars richer just putting it
that way
everybody um uh one other thing ryan
about phil
all these years following him in a way
it's been like following your favorite
team
like uh you know pick your pick your
squad if
you're a warriors fan if you're a red
sox fan philly fan whatever it is
over the course of your lifetime you you
root for them and you
know they're gonna break your heart
right they're going to miss
a 35-yard field goal down
to with four seconds to go in the super
bowl
they're gonna just crush you but
they're gonna hit a grand slam in the
bottom of the ninth game seven of the
world series
that's mickelson right he's walked
arm-in-arm
with calamity on one side and glory on
the other
for a long time and what i think phil's
greatest asset has always been beyond
the sort of physical
genius the genius he has for the sport
is that he he he's comfortable with risk
he assesses it i think you know most of
the times he assesses it
fairly prudently but he's comfortable
with
risk and with what comes if it doesn't
work
out he he he knows
that in this game if you're good enough
you're going to be there on sunday and
you're going to fall
on your ass right you're going to be
embarrassed and he he's
phil has this sort of understanding that
it's just a game
and he's always been he's always been
really good at
packing up that baggage that you that
you
pick up through the years in sport right
you you were there
he's been good with picking that baggage
up in one of the next tournament the
next stop
attacking and getting after it again and
you have to have that attitude
i think uh to be a truly great uh
performer
yeah you your ability to have a quick
memory uh we're talking with rich lerner
uh here talking about the us open phil
mickelson uh he's from the golf channel
all right
so if not phil who there are a bunch
that are
are always around i always feel like uh
in this day and age
um anybody uh who enters who is
qualified for this u.s
open is capable of winning it who are
the guys that everybody's really keeping
an eye on this week
heading into torrey pines
look at the recent winners in the u.s
opening you know for
whatever missteps the usga may have made
in in recent years
agronomic issues at uh chambers bay
uh bad hole location shinnecock kills in
2018.
they have identified you could argue the
best players so
in 2015 it was jordan spieth and it was
dustin johnson and brooks kepta one back
to back
gary woodland and last september at wink
but it was brighton to shambo so
i would counsel people look at uh
look at that if not the chalk then then
you know the premium
the premium guys uh it's a it's a long
uh muscular straight forward golf course
which they're they're almost all
familiar with because they play here at
the farmer's insurance in january
though brooks missed the cut last
weekend you know
you can't look past what he does at
major championships he's
far and away going back to 2017 far and
away
the best player at major championships
just has a different mindset
uh and i you know i'll go there because
it's too obvious right now given
what's going on between the two but
bryson's a guy
you you have to look at a long golf
course uh
i think he'll you know take advantage of
his length uh the rough is up but it was
up
as well at wing foot and and he putted
extremely well at wing foot
uh in winning his speed's ankle is okay
i always like jordan i think jordan's
all the way back i think xander schofley
uh
may have finally figured out how to play
this golf course he was born and raised
here
um so xander's a guy i think uh
you take a look at um
and uh i mean keep going but
i i won't bore you um no
take take a look at you know your top 20
players in the world and work
work within that i would say i like it
rich lerner from the golf channel here
um we've been
discussing on the show just the the
pseudo-feud that has been going on
between bryce and dechambeau
and brooks kepca and how the media and
how the fans and everybody has picked up
on it and actually
uh thrown more gasoline on it than than
probably either one of the two
uh uh have actually intended on on their
parts
what's been your thought in uh and
moving moving the game of golf forward
because it's talked about more or is it
something that
uh you know as everybody knows bryson's
a different
different cat right and when you're
different uh sometimes you're mocked
and not looked upon the same way and
i've i've seen it differently with how
brooks has handled this
and how his fan base has kind of
followed up in the process
right um they're not going to be paired
together
right the groupings are out so i know a
lot of people wanted to see that
um a few thoughts on this
you know i understand it's a different
time now and
you know
the social media score um you know
earns money in in the same way that the
score on the card
uh 67 64. in the same way score in the
card earns money now
uh you know what i think is that brooks
kepka
is playing a game here and
um it's intentional um
calculated he he he knows what he's
doing
in an attempt to in his eyes and and
probably right to generate some interest
um
and uh because that's where people live
now they live
uh you know largely on social media
we're all carrying our phones and
checking
uh this feed or that feed so um
it it's clearly intentional uh and he's
on there selling beer and maybe he'll
land a seven
figure exhibition match i would look for
for phil mickelson who's sort of the
impresario of these these uh these
made for television matches that feature
aaron rodgers and tom brady
my money it says that he'll put the
duchambeau and kept it together before
the end of the year i don't know that
for a fact but i'm just guessing
so uh this is a game that brooks uh has
determined he wants to
play uh and he does have uh he's
generating a following
it's it's you know sort of bar stool um
um
and and that that's uh his crowd and um
does it generate interest i i guess uh
my only concern would be
is if he's inviting his fans his
followers
in some way even if it's not overt to
to heckle bryson then i think some sort
of a line has been crossed there
yeah um and uh i would add just for
perspective here
you know there are there are gains uh
and
and and feuds and battles um
you know and it's kind of child's play
and then there's the the following
uh which i'll share with you this is the
75th anniversary
of lloyd mangram's u.s open win in 1946.
before the u.s open a couple of years
before lloyd mangram
was a hard scrabble pro from texas was
offered a club job
in maryland it would have kept them out
of world war ii he turned down that club
job and he
served he went to fight tyranny in
europe
he was injured in normandy in the battle
of the bulge he was awarded two purple
hearts
before going into battle
he was with his best friend they ripped
up a dollar bill in half and they agreed
that they would reunite and put that
dollar bill back together
after the war they'd meet up again
soon after his best friend was killed
mangram hung onto that dollar bill for
the rest of his days
and six months after returning from the
war
manga made a seven footer in a driving
rainstorm
in ohio to win the u.s open
so i i would you know put all of this
this stuff aside i think every player
here would welcome the chance to have a
seven footer in the san diego sunshine
to win a u.s open so all of this is my
in my
in the grand scheme it's much to do
about nothing you know but but it's kind
of a modern
it's it's kind of a modern wrinkle in in
in in sports it's not just uh the action
on the field of play there's something
going on on twitter there's some beef
there's some controversy i mean every
week we go there's something
something somebody said something wrote
something tweeted something
um and uh so um
onward we go i think there'll be an
impact probably they'll have to
it's something they're going to have to
in the ryder cup team room later this
year
that'll be written about so look if if
the measurement
is clicks and and and people talking
about it
writing about it then i suppose it's
it's been a roaring success
uh this little feud whatever you want to
call it um
but i don't i don't put a lot of stock
in it i prefer
you know i prefer my rivalries uh to be
played out
on the course i'd love to see them uh
together uh late sunday
in the final final group then we really
have something
me too could happen that could happen
because look these two have won three of
the last four us opens they're both
phenomenal talent i mean just phenomenal
you know uh strong dudes uh great
competitors
um all of that and uh you know i think
some of this goes back to
to a few years ago when brooks won two
majors in one year and was left off
uh espn's list of dominant athletes
he had a legitimate right right two of
these things in one year you're
you're dominant in your sport and i
think brooks uh
uh determined at that point in time that
he was going to be heard
uh not simply with his golf clubs but in
in the more
modern ways uh that you know that
athletes are
are are putting themselves in front of
the public
and uh i think he's you know in some
ways cleverly
figured out this is this is where you
where you can do it poke and tweak
and troll a little bit and uh in his
eyes probably have
have a little little fun uh but again i
think if we're out there
on thursday or friday and bryson's
getting heckled then
then it's a little bit of a of a problem
i would suspect that security will be on
the lookout for all of that this week
we'll see how it goes well i can tell
you something rich you are a hell of a
storyteller i had never heard that story
uh about the 75th anniversary of the us
open uh yeah
ingram lloyd mangram was uh
some some kind of human being well yeah
everybody who uh isn't living in this
generation uh who went through those
types of things and
and our fathers um that's that's the
generation they'll never
never sacrifice uh what what those men
and women
did for us um so um i'm looking forward
to this really is a battle right ryan
really is a battle we talk about oh
there's battle or there's a there's a
feud
yeah this really is it's all it's all
relative it is all relative and i
appreciate you telling that story rich
lerner everybody
from the golf channel enjoy sunny sunny
san diego this week my friend
thank you brian i appreciate it hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here